This video is brought to you by Danish class one Oh one pod one Oh one and class
one Oh one courses are one of my favorite ways to start learning a new language
online. Click the link in the description or visit Lang
focused.com/danish class. To give it a try. Finally, today,
we're going to talk about the Danish language so I can explore my Danish roots.
No, no, I am Danish. No, wait,
my name is Danish.
Uh, yeah, I can't say that.
Hello everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul today.
We're going to focus on the Danish language to Dennis this ball,
or just dense as it's called in Danish.
There are around 6 million native speakers of Danish, mainly in Denmark,
including Greenland,
but also in the state of shoelace V Holstine in Northern Germany.
It's also an official language in the Faroe islands though.
It's learned as a second language. They're just like Swedish and Norwegian.
Danish is a continental North Germanic language.
It has historically formed a dialect continuum with Swedish and Norwegian and on
paper. It's very similar to them,
but when spoken it's normally quite difficult for Swedish and Norwegian speakers
to understand because of its complex phonology,
a common joke is that Dane sounded like they're speaking with a potato stuck in
their throat or with a mouth full of porridge.
That's partly because lots of the phonemes that Swedish and Norwegian speakers
would clearly pronounce. It seems to be slurred or even disappear in Danish,
but as we'll see later, many of those pronunciation quirks are systematic.
And at least to some extent, predictable,
the North dramatic languages all descended from old Norse,
which developed from prodo Germanic by the eighth century.
Some variation began to develop an old North and it diverged into old West,
North and old East North,
which diverged into old Danish and old Swedish by around the 13th century.
As I mentioned in my video on Swedish,
all these North's is sometimes referred to as either runic,
Swedish or runic Danish, depending on its location.
This name reflects the fact that it was written in the runic alphabet by the
time Danish had developed into a separate language from Swedish in the 13th
century,
the written language of Denmark was Latin and Danish was mainly written in the
Latin alphabet though.
It continued to be written with runes to a limited extent in the mid 14th
century, Danish began to be used as an administrative language though.
The written language was not yet standardized.
So dialectical variation and different spelling choices were evident in writing
and just like Swedish and Norwegian Danish vocabulary was significantly
influenced by low German during the Hanseatic expansion in the 16th
century,
Latin ceased to be the exclusive language of Christianity because of the
Protestant reformation and the first Danish Bible published in 1550
as was the case with many languages of Europe.
This went a long way towards making Danisha literary language and towards
standardizing it. But during this time,
the characteristic phonological features that set Danish apart from Swedish and
Norwegian were also developing in the following centuries.
Numerous Danish grammars were written as well as an increasing amount of
literature in the 17th century.
The variety of Danish used by the Danish chancellery became the defacto standard
language and served as the basis for as standard.
Danish is called today.
One noteworthy feature of this variety of Danish was the uvular R sound.
Unlike the rolled R in other words,
the alveolar R which is used in most areas of Sweden and Norway,
universal education,
increased literacy and national broadcasting in the 20th century spread the
standard language to every region,
making the language fairly uniform throughout the country.
Dialects are now mainly limited to elderly speakers in certain areas.
Danish is well-known for being difficult to pronounce and difficult to
understand due to its relatively complex phonology people often describe it as
not being clearly enunciated.
One book that I've seen prefers the euphemisms soft and indistinct,
and many sounds become reduced or dropped in Danish, for example, this word,
meaning product. So take a look at the spelling and imagine what it sounds like.
Well, here's how it sounds in Danish.
There is far from being a one-to-one relationship between letters and sounds.
You have to learn the sounds that various letter combinations make too,
as well as the way certain sounds change depending on the other sounds
surrounding them. Do you remember this phrase from the beginning of the video,
we'll run the flu meaning red fruit pudding with cream pay attention to the D
sounds we'll run the flu.
The Danish D is pronounced in a few different ways at the beginning of a
syllable. It sounds like the, or maybe like without aspiration,
it's pronounced in a different way.
When it comes after a vowel in a syllable Coda. In other words,
it's not at the beginning of a syllable.
This is the soft D sound in many books and courses it's
described as a soft sound like an English. The,
but it really doesn't sound like that. Listen to this example, meaning fat.
So the soft D is often perceived as an L sound law by
non-native speakers.
It's typically a valorized laminal alveolar approximate rather than trying to
wrap our heads around what that is.
Let's just think about how to make a good attempt at producing it.
When you make a voice, the sound,
the tip of your tongue is between your upper and lower teeth.
But when you make the Danish soft D sound,
the tip of your tongue touches the back of your lower teeth.
And as you're making the sound,
the rest of your tongue kind of rises and moves forward,
bringing it close to the roof of your mouth,
your tongue never fully contacts the roof of your mouth,
making it an approximate rather than a fricative D is also not pronounced
after L or N or before T or S for example, in ELA,
meaning an age Sen,
meaning the devil G is also soft at the end of words.
And between voice sounds in a syllable Coda,
that means its place of articulation opens up and it changes from a stop to an
approximate it's almost silent or silent. For example,
it meaning a choice and they meaning bake
G is also pronounced as one of the two vowel elements in several diphthongs.
As we'll see in a minute, the letter V is also pronounced as an approximate,
not usually a fricative Viva, for example,
V is silent after L for example.
So meaning self and meaning floor.
It's also silent after the vowel.
Oo and V is pronounced as the second element in some diphthongs,
as we'll see in a minute at the beginning of words are as pronounced as
a voiced uvular fricative or a voiced uvular approximate
at the back of the throat. For example, at the end of words,
it's pronounced as a vowel for example,
and that's also true after a vowel in a syllable Coda, vowels,
Danish vowels can be either short or long,
and many of them can be pronounced more than one way,
depending on the other sounds adjacent to them. For example,
when the letter a comes before or after R it's pronounced, ah,
for example, in other contexts,
it's pronounced more like app when it's a short vowel than sphere.
And it's more like a, when it's a long vowel, for example,
meaning paint E is pronounced a either as a short or long vowel
it's, but can also be either short or long after our says,
and it can be pronounced as a Schwab or become silent at the end.
May day.
Danish stands out amongst the continental North Germanic languages for having
lots of diphthongs. There are two categories,
those with E as the second element, and those with OU as the second element.
Hi, my
no ULI blue
SU UWA stolen lo Bo,
how, how Gail.
Notice that there are many cases when a combination of a vowel plus G or V
represents a diphthong that's because at least in some contexts they are
approximates then because approximates are close to vowels,
the vowel plus approximate combinations become diphthongs.
Unlike Swedish and Norwegian, Danish does not have pitch accent,
but it does have phony mix stress accent.
The meanings of some words are distinguished by differences in stress.
For example.
It is one.
Unique phonological feature of Danish that other North Germanic languages don't
have is called stew.
This is like a glottal stop without complete closure of the vocal chords
resulting in what's described as a creaky voice it's phonemic and its presence
can distinguish words that otherwise sound the same. For example, Hoon,
meaning she versus who meaning dog.
Hoon, who.
Maya meaning me versus my meaning may as in the month of may,
it can appear in syllables with a long vowel or in syllables with a short vowel
followed by a voiced consonant.
This phonological feature is not present in some dialects,
specifically Southern Danish dialects.
Now let's look at some sentences in order to examine some of the grammatical
features of Danish.
I film meaning I saw a film word for word it's.
I saw a film.
The word order is the same as an English S V O N is the indefinite
article. The definite equivalent of this sentence is cinnamon.
Meaning I saw the film.
The definite article is a suffix that attaches to the end of the now unlike the
definite article in English that comes before the now Danish has two genders,
common gender and neuter. Gender is a common gender now for our neuter.
Now the article is.
It's also who's.
I saw a house notice that the pronunciation of the articles becomes reduced
in full sentences since they're not emphasized as keywords. Yeah.
So I saw the house,
plural nouns also taken definite and definite endings,
but rather than depending on gender, they fall into one of three now in classes.
Yeah. So I saw two films. Yeah. So the minute I saw the films,
this non-class takes no suffix on the indefinite plural and the suffix,
the unit on the definite plural. I saw two houses.
Yeah. So whose I saw the houses in this now in class,
the indefinite form has the suffix, but pronounced like a Schwab.
And the definite form has the suffix.
Nana in Bo bone, Briana.
This class,
the indefinite form takes the suffix and the definite form takes the suffix.
There were also some irregular nouns with different plural forms.
Yeah. So it wouldn't fantastic. You feel them?
I saw the fantastic film word for word. I saw that fantastic film.
When an adjective is used in a sentence,
the definite article suffix is replaced by a standalone definite article that
comes before the,
now the common gender one is then the neuter one is D the
plural one is D for both genders.
[Inaudible].
Tomorrow. He's flying to London word for word it's tomorrow,
fly QI to London.
The sentences we saw before followed SVO word order,
but not every sentence is SVO rather the continental North Germanic languages
feature V2 world order.
That means that if an adverb or another element of the sentence comes first,
the verb will come next.
And the subject will come after the verb in Danish and the other North Germanic
languages. This applies to main clauses,
but not to embedded clauses though in Icelandic,
it applies to both before we saw the first person singular
subject pronoun. And here we see the third person, singular subject pronoun,
Danish, personal pronouns are similar to those of English,
except that the equivalent of it has both common gender and neuter forms.
And there's a second person, plural pronoun,
which standard English doesn't have, of course in vernacular English.
People have different ways of expressing the second person, plural,
like you all y'all you guys, et cetera.
But none of those are really part of the standard language Angie finished in
COVID. He can't find his suitcase word for word it.
He cannot find his suitcase.
This possessive scene is not on the chart. It's an additional third person,
singular possessive adjective and pronoun,
which indicates that the subject of the sentence is the possessor.
So this sentence means that he can't find his own suitcase in this sentence.
The meaning is that he can't find a different person.
Suitcase scene is common gender,
but there's a neuter gender equivalent seats and the plural equivalent scene.
There are equivalents of these in Swedish and Norwegian as well.
Notice the negative marker here, which comes after the auxiliary verb. Ken,
in this particular case,
the English syntax is the same since we say can't or cannot,
but in many present tense sentences in English we use do not.
While Danish doesn't use any equivalent of do almost no languages do
in Danish. The negative always comes after.
The verb. These busy, we don't.
Eat meat. How about the verb itself?
As in Swedish and Norwegian verbs are not conjugated for person or number.
So this present tense verb is exactly the same,
no matter who the subject is in the past, it's always crooner, et cetera.
Regular verbs are divided into two classes.
Those which end in T E and those which end in EDU.
Species's eat speeds to eight who's drew. Remember who's who.
Remembered and just drove up. [inaudible] his suitcase.
Wasn't found word for word. His suitcase became not found.
This is a passive sentence.
The passive here is formed by using the verb blue to become plus the past
participle meaning found another way to form the passive is by adding
S to the active form for regular verbs. Or in this case, E S.
Sent found fenders was found.
But this passive form takes on a different meaning.
So this would actually mean existed.
So the form with you is the only one to use here and.
Heartfulness less. Ooh, econ. He has only.
50 Euros in cash word for word.
He has only 50 Euro in cash.
Notice the word for 50 and Danish.
Danish has a very unusual way of forming numbers from 50 to 100,
which is not found in the other North dramatic languages.
They developed from multiples of 20, rather than multiples of 10.
The word for 50 means something like half, three times,
meaning three times 20 minus half of 2060 is
says, meaning three times three times 2070 is, has jazz.
Meaning half, four, times 80 is CS,
meaning four times 90 years, meaning half,
five times in the equivalent ordinal numbers.
We can see the unappreciated form of the numbers,
which shows their etymology 50.
As, as June, since.
Is the genitive of soon, which means times, but it's an archaic word.
The modern word is, and it's generated.
Form is Gunness 60th it's classes,
tune 70th.
How disasters June 80th fuses junar 90th had a fem since
June.
If you're familiar with either of the other continental North Germanic languages
that I'm sure it's obvious to you,
that Danish is similar to them for the most part,
with some difference in grammar spelling,
a little bit more difference in vocabulary.
And most of all differences in pronunciation,
the phonological developments that have taken place in Danish mean that one
phoneme can have a variety of sounds,
depending on the other sounds that surround it.
And that the sounds often don't correspond to the spelling of words,
but hopefully you've seen that there are some patterns to those differences and
that it's far from impossible to learn Danish pronunciation,
especially for speakers of Swedish and Norwegian who have trouble understanding
Danish. I think it would be pretty easy to learn,
to understand it by learning those patterns and then getting lots of exposure to
Danish. The question of the day.
I think I've asked a similar question before in another video,
but for speakers of Danish,
how easy is it for you to communicate with Norwegian and Swedish speakers?
Are you able to adjust your speech so that they can understand you and Norwegian
and Swedish speakers?
Are you able to communicate with Danish speakers and other people?
What's your impression of Danish, which of its features stand out to you?
I hope this has been an interesting and entertaining look at the Danish
language, but if you want to develop actual skills in the language,
then click the link in the description to visit Danish class one Oh one or visit
Lang focused.com/danish class.
It's the most extensive Danish course I've ever seen with literally hundreds of
lessons for learners of any level and the lessons get progressively more
challenging as your level improves as the name suggests they're podcast based
lessons,
which is great for people who like to learn using audio materials and for people
who want to learn on the go these days,
I try to focus much more on audio materials than I used to so that I can build
my listening comprehension and do my best to native pronunciation,
but class one Oh one and pod one Oh one courses offer more than just audio
lessons. They have lots of video lessons,
as well as downloadable books and PDF materials so that you can get visual input
and explanations of all the language introduced in the lessons.
They also have audio recordings of the individual words and phrases.
So you can review them individually and you can create vocabulary flashcards
that use spaced repetitions to help you memorize the words more easily.
They also offer quizzes to help you review lessons,
word lists of the most commonly used words and other features for class one Oh
one and pod one Oh one courses in general,
I recommend using the additional tools such as the downloadable lesson notes and
the space repetition flashcards to review and solidify what you learned in each
lesson before moving on to the next one for Danish specifically,
I really recommend you focus on the lesson vocabulary words and their recordings
so that you can hear each individual word clearly pronounced and imitate it.
If you have an awareness of the features of Danish pronunciation,
like those mentioned in this video,
and then you practice imitating the pronunciation of the individual words while
observing their spelling,
that should be of tremendous help in taking on Danish phonology.
I've never learned a language using only a class one Oh one or a pod one Oh one
course, but I'm a member of several of their courses.
And I regularly use them as part of my study program. Lots of content is free,
including all new lessons, which are free for the first couple of weeks.
And then if you want access to all the content you can upgrade to a paid
account. I really recommend you check out innovative language courses,
whether for Danish or one of 33 other languages,
they offer click the link in the description to get a free lifetime account.
I also want to give a big shout out to all the Lang focus, Patrion supporters,
especially the top tier patrons whose names are on the screen. Check out
patrion.com/lang focus and check out the benefits of the various tiers and to
everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice day.